no i realize you normally reorder in
november but what i'm suggesting
you did what oh no that's exactly what
you're not supposed to do damn it
why would you reorder from a computer
when you could have the personal touch
of a salesman
it going fine good yeah yeah
you look a little worried i do not look
worried
i am not a bad person when i left
staples i took some of their leads with
me but i never intended to use them
what did i intend to do with them who
knows maybe
keep them as a souvenir maybe use them
yes mr galliato how would you like to
pay 10 less for
paper than you're paying right now it's
not important now i got your information
what is important is that you say yes
good yes 10 reams for the u.s district
court
did i happen to mention the 40 reams for
the battered women's shelter no
huh
[Music]
stop it give me that give it did you see
the board
there's still an hour
four three two
one yes
after numerous projections that the
computer would crush
all salesmen in its path i am very happy
to report that our very own
dewite charroot has crushed
his electronic nemesis if you will
by a whopping 52
wait say it say it again announce it
again 52 reasons
so first part dwight has defeated the
computer
hey so
what do you think i did it for you
i didn't ask you to do it for me you
didn't have to
how do you tell someone it's over you
send them a notarized letter right
well what if the recipient is your
notary
hello pam hello hey
do you have any men that you can fix me
up with i would like to have a
relationship with a man
um i'll i'll get back to you
let me know
hello my name is ron swanson
in general i try never to speak with
people but i have been drinking this
snake juice thing and it's damn good
you should buy it yeah okay thanks man
son you should know that my
recommendation is essentially a
guarantee
drink this now
okay jim you owe me 120 and
phil you owe me 230.
let's open a tab because you and me are
gonna be playing more often
count me in nope all right
okay we had some fun and uh i think i
paid for it
so let me just get my last shot in there
is there anything you can do for me
i'll tell you what my fiscal year ends
in two months
let's talk then sound good absolutely
you're playing with you guys
you know it's a tough thing seeing a
grown man take six shots to get out of a
sand trap but
i had to give phil credit for not
quitting which is what i told him
i also told him that i don't quit either
and i'd call him every single day until
he gave me his business
which he then did after 15 minutes of me
blocking his car
so i am now his paper supplier
and i shot at 102 today so i'm feeling
pretty good
this one's twice as much but it comes
with a built-in bean hopper yeah i
i doubt you'd ever use most of these
features are you sure
cause i'm leaning toward the expensive
one and i can't stress enough
money is no object honestly unless
you're like a barista
i think you're better off with just a
regular auto drip
all right i guess i'll spend the
difference on lotto tickets
although realistically what are my
chances of winning twice
jonah so the red team knows about the
money now
so it's time for the gold team to stop
pussyfooting around
i'm not doing that with my feet i just
have trouble pressuring people into
buying stuff they don't need well that's
selfish actually i think it's the
opposite of selfish come on jonah you're
better than this look at the red team
brett just sold a shelf not the items on
the shelf he sold an
actual shelf yeah well that's brett
guy's a machine
what up playboy you like that jacket
it's a pretty dope cut right
yeah can i have it mom i could wear it
to homecoming
300 bucks for something you're just
gonna grow out of in a month forget it
wait i can rent it to you really
yeah it's part of a business i run
high-end clothes rentals for teens
tweens and everything in betweens
that jacket is 20 bucks a week
done this is a great idea he grows so
fast i never want to buy him anything
nice
what's the name of your business
rent-a-swag
jim and i have different definitions of
friendship i think it's talking and
being friends and jim thinks
it's moving to connecticut and being
best friends with josh well
fooly on that i uh
i'm done i'm not going to be speaking
with him anymore
whatevs long-distance relationships
never work that is so true
ready mm-hmm okay let me tell you what
we're looking for okay
sorry my meeting ran late really
yes jan really with a rep from hammer
mill
they're exclusive with staples used to
be evan i'll call you in the morning to
work out the details we can now sell
hammer mill products
yes well michael
i just i underestimated you
yeah well maybe next time you will
estimate me
my fertility clinic has a booth at the
manhattan fertility expo yeah we started
a pretty innovative new program it's to
convince girls in their 20s to want to
freeze their eggs
it's called later baby and it was my
idea
i'm a business partner frisbee
sorry really no takers for a free dinner
unbelievable
you lot would turn down a free car if it
was from me wait who's giving away a
free car
um i'm good i i mean just
tamara hey we were wondering if we could
run our spiel for the fertility expo by
you cause you're young and millennial
right
perfect do you know there's no better
time to freeze your eggs than when
you're in your 20s mm-hmm and it's a
great way to make sure that your
reproductive health is
on fleek and that is cool
you think you're a bigger minions fan
than me i don't think so
cause if you were you would have a
minions
blanket and a minions
nightlight and some minions candy
and this princess thing
one second hey babe what's up uh yeah
yeah i just want to run something by you
oh i'm really busy right now can't wait
well i was just at home and i i realized
we were out of double-a batteries
so i had to do double-a batteries i'll
bring some home okay love you bye
that was the head minion
and he told me to tell you to tell your
mom
to get you a new xbox hire very good
building company for your construction
needs
or do not i am not a beggar
end of commercial
you